thank you kathy thanks counselor jessica
um i don't think i need to say anything
about the net zero strategy or the heat
and building strategy anymore because
you've got the figures there
um so i'm shivali mathur uh from heat
networks department market growth uh
supply chain and new entrants so i think
was really really good i know kathy
mentioned that
it's nice to be in person with everyone
and i can feel the enthusiasm and the
passion
in the local area about the eco energy
as you said it's really nice to have
those direct conversations um we had one
conference last month and it was really
really good so glad to be here thank you
so much
um following some really positive
announcements and if i take flashback to
last year was the prime minister's
10-point plan
and again i think jessica said about the
role of private sector it highlighted
the importance of green finance in this
green industrial revolution
um and obviously we've had continued
announcements about the heat building
strategy
and the net zero strategy uh proud to
say that we still have the continued
financial support of 338 million pounds
on the broader heat network
transformation program
um
do i need sorry sorry i didn't ask for a
flick
rate and commit to net zero emissions by
2050
and we have seen a since significant
progress since 1990 levels but in 2017
uk actually returned to energy related
emissions similar to 1888
um and again i think council jessica had
the number of 40 there
and in my view that's big achievement so
we are in the path the right path and
yes there's lots to be done uh to be net
zero by 2050.
heating is essential to our lives and
probably one of the biggest reason um we
consume energy in our society it is
responsible for over a third of our
emissions
we have made good progress in
decarbonizing electricity and had a very
good chat with a gentleman on
the ev scooters
back there that was my first
conversation of this morning
so we have made good progress in that
side um it is recognized in our clean
growth strategy that decarbonization of
heat is the next big challenge
and couple of things were mentioned that
being expensive or it doesn't work so
some sort of perceptions in the market
there is also transport and industry in
fact which faces challenges
the recently published heat building
strategy i am going to mention it does
set out um how uk will decarbonize our
homes
our commercial industrial and public
sector buildings as part of setting a
net zero
to net zero by 2050.
in our clean growth strategy we have
identified a few different pathways on
heating the buildings
and in all of them
heat networks play a key role
so these pathways are typically thought
of as low carbon gas
hydrogen
green gas injected to the grid or the
electric electrification pathway
which could be big heat pumps could be
electric heaters
or hybrids as we transition
heat networks are technology agnostic
which makes them so versatile and we see
them almost playing a role in all of
these pathways
but our position has been consistent for
last few years in terms of forecasting
for long term
that is heat networks will play a vital
role and they're absolutely key part of
the future energy system
so just to give some numbers and
statistics today we have around 14 000
heat networks out of which 2000 are
district level heat networks and 12 000
are communal networks
they serve around 500 000 plus customers
but to give you a bit more pro
perspective on what are these district
and communal heat networks and how do
they distinguish
district heat networks distribute
thermal energy in the form of hot water
steam or liquids chill liquids from a
central source of production
in form of pipes or distribution through
a network to multiple buildings
for the use of space heating hot water
and cooling
et cetera they can also generate
electricity
if you want to differentiate from a
communal network
that is similar central source of
production inside a building so when you
have the apartments and you've got a
central boiler in there connecting to a
central heat pump in future as i would
say
connecting to all those flats would
constitute a communal heat network
again to give a bit more perspective on
what does that relate to um percentage
of annual heat demand
of uk and how much do we fulfill
so these 14 000 heat networks cover
around 2.4 percent of uk's annual heat
demand currently
and in our ccc is the the ccc report
which is committee on climate change
it estimated that in 2050
that that could be as much as 18
so if you if you look at the trajectory
from 2.5 percent now and 18
there's a massive pathway for us to in a
big journey to
to work on and
again i think as mentioned role of
private sector is going to be quite key
on that
thinking about this in terms of terror
is because i think slowly slowly the
country is going into kilowatt hours
megawatt hours and terawatts
um in 2050 that 18
implies 80 to 90 terawatt hours of heat
delivered from heat networks which is a
sizeable chunk and what weaker and
what's considered by committee on
climate change
as one of the most effective pathway to
reach our carbon targets
to enable this so what support is
provided by the government
we have a lot of government support
available
in addition to the team support so you
can come to our team discuss about the
networks and the opportunities in
addition to that government now backs
heat networks with more than half a
billion pounds
namely with our flagship project
program the capital support program
called h nip the first one heat networks
investment project
followed by green heat network fund
i'll cover a little bit in detail later
on
we recently announced um the 270 million
pound green heat network fund which is
targeted to support to decarbonize
existing you know the 14 000 networks
and the new heat networks
it's expected to launch in 2022.
beehive is bay's heat investment vehicle
it's a dynamic purchasing system for
heat networks which allows public sector
and i know the councils are here today
it allows them um
allows the local authorities and the
heat network owners
to procure funding and funding related
services for their heat network projects
from a range of funding providers so
when this be in this dynamic purchasing
system we would have already gone
through a wetting system and you would
have credible funding providers
and this beehive is applicable for
england and for wales
we are supporting local authorities to
designate
new heat network zones no later than
2025.
zoning entails identification of
new identification of areas which can be
connected to a low-carbon heat network
uh zoning consultation is out now and if
anyone wants a link or needs needs to
feedback uh happy i'm happy to take the
feedback as well
just to give a little bit more about
18 the heat network transformation
program has hndu h ghn f but if i can
zoom into our team support from heat
network delivery unit which could be
useful to a few few here
local authorities have a very key role
to play
in making heat networks succeed
their involvement can help realize the
benefits of heat networks
which also delivers jobs and growth
again i think kathy mentioned about the
big number of jobs in the strategy
documents which have come out
established in 2013 hndu the heat
network delivery unit provides support
in funding and in specialist support to
local authorities in developing these
projects
um where's the demand where's the supply
i think there was mentioned about air
source heat pumps ground source heat
pumps or mine water
river etc
we've supported 250 plus projects
across 150 local authorities in
different funding rounds
which is an awarding in excess of 23
million pounds
just from hntu
we talk about green heat network fund a
little bit
details because that might be
interesting
um
hnip the capital flagship program the
support program which is going to end
this year
how many projects it's funded this this
number is as of
march so this is as of last round 165
million pound has been funded across
different
projects and
the ones in the orange specifically
zooms to few of them in this area as
well
so very positive
what does that mean in
kilometers of pipe what does that imply
in how many residents have been
connected or how many buildings have
been connected
that equates to annual heat delivered by
these heat network projects under the
government funded projects as 255
gigawatt hours
52 000 homes to be connected
uh across those projects
227 non-residential buildings
and pipes put under the ground
approximately 128 kilometer
and the total capex of these funded
projects and if you see it's
approximately one is to three the ratio
was 421 million
the most important figure which i've put
it in dark sort of thing is
what is the estimated carbon saved which
is i think the essence of why we are
here today as well
716 000
tons carbon dioxide tons of carbon
dioxide equivalent and that's that's the
number which which for me is the most
important bit
um
for future
green heat network fund uh which is
coming next year
it is a three-year capital grant scheme
which will run from april 2022 to 25.
um total is 270 million and it's quite
important to say across england and
wales
why is being designed
to incentivize the heat network market
to move away from high carbon
heat sources to low carbon heat sources
so i'm echoing you again kathy when you
said there's going to be an end to
fossil fuel hopefully
soon
the green heat network fund they connect
both existing heat networks and the new
heat networks to low carbon heat sources
and focuses on low carbon heat
production
they will be open to range of low carbon
technologies
more than happy afterwards if anyone
wants to have discussion on technologies
it will help build the momentum of
previous projects such as the heat
network investment project and ensure
that there is no limit there's limited
or no funding gap in the market for heat
networks
and that could bring confidence and
growth in the market
just graphic but i'm i'm mindful that
i didn't get them quite clear so i'm
going to explain that a little bit
um
i think by now we've we've all
sort of tuned into that heat
decarbonization is next big
challenge transformation
for the energy system
the action now is essential to meet the
carbon targets and to achieve
significant transformation
on the left side if you see the graph
the x-axis is the
emissions savings required from 2015 to
2050 measured in metric tons
of carbon dioxide equivalent and on the
y-axis is the percentage emissions
reductions
i think what is most important for us is
the big red circle on um on this graph
on the right side
which shows that the emissions are
coming majority of them from heat in
buildings and industry
which is equivalent to 166 metric tons
of carbon carbon dioxide equivalent if
you then see on the right side if you
divide that
heat almost the emissions
whether where does that then come into
from sector sector perspective that's
domestic heat
public and commercial buildings and
industrial buildings so just reinforcing
the fact that yes
there's a lot of attention needed on
that side
and hence again the importance of heat
building strategy
so the opportunity
um
coming back on space heating
cooling hot water
we would say at 21
heating cooling and hot water in
buildings is one of the biggest source
of uk emissions
much of this is attributed to the
individual gas boilers that produce 85
of heating in homes um
so in our pathway to net zero we need to
end the fossil fuels
but why heat networks
this is one of my um
favorites slides i would say so why do
we like heat networks
they do not save carbon on their own
but they unlock
some of the really exciting large scale
low carbon sources
of heat that's available right the way
across the country
and whether that is energy from waste
plants which is everywhere across the
country because we need
we need them
or is it's the heat from mine workings
or that heat is from the river
along with the host of other sources
because of the greater efficiencies the
improved performances
the ability to trade on the system there
was a word used previously the smart
ecosystems
store energy in the thermal storages and
to respond to the wider energy system
what we are doing by heat networks is
enabling a much more
uh effective use of energy in meeting
that demand
a very very quick overview on uh
just looking at the time
a super quick overlook on
the trajectory on how we're working at
the minute as i mentioned that hnep
comes to an end
and then it's
then comes ghnf which is part of the
heat network transformation program
also part of the heat network
transformation program is the skills
program
last year chancellor made an
announcement during the sr um and the
hntp was announced
the gist of the heat network
transformation program is the skills and
supply chain which is almost the
backbone for any technology for any
growth
we need the skills we need the supply
chain to grow
for to be able to deliver these
technologies in future
zoning as i mentioned earlier is going
to designate those areas and then you we
also have the future home standard as
mentioned into the
heat and building strategy with the name
of 600 000 heat pumps a year per
thousand
thirty
a very quick one i'm sure i think the
slides are gonna be shared but more than
happy to oh yeah okay i've got the not
there um so i've i've put some links
there which could be useful um the heat
network planning database has the heat
network projects across the uk which are
in the planning process so there are
that's across the whole country um so
i'm sure whatever is available locally
you can see but also um for far off as
well
you can see the emerging trends which
which will uh hopefully increase market
confidence as we move towards
uh 2050. um there is a geographical
spread and there's an interactive map
which would be quite useful um
everyone
thank you
so any ques i don't know if you're doing
a q a now or
from the floor otherwise i'll come up
with one or two myself but if you can
yeah gentlemen there thank you the um
my perception is that heat networks are
widely used on the continent
but used infrequently in the uk
i wonder if you could indicate why that
is it suggests there's some legislative
or taxation issue that drives people
away from the solution you're proposing
uh which has significant advantages
obviously
could you expand why do you believe
there is that difference
yes
i would slightly echo what the industry
has been saying as well some of the
barriers
project development time
and the costs
i'm sorry i didn't get your name
but
sorry councillor john field of
mid-suffolk district council thank you
council
um so there's a plethora of barriers on
this one um well has been in the past
but project level up in time say for
instance so i mentioned about the heat
network delivery unit
when a local authority thinks that there
are possible heat networks in their area
that would come and talk to us which is
almost like we do a master planning
study at a very high level which is
geogra you almost see it from a
satellite from a gis mapping um where is
the demand and where is the supply for
that particular area that would take you
around three to four months to study
that to study the area
then you go into details of feasibility
so if you've got a library council
library a council office and you want to
then connect it to an energy from waste
plant you have three different
stakeholders including involved in this
and you almost need those legal
contracts and head of them signed
between both of them with the price of
pens per kilowatt hour this is what i'm
going to give this is what you're going
to get for 30 to 40 years
so traditionally i think these things
have taken time
and to now because this is now a
established model and learning from
other international markets
we are looking to introduce zoning which
would be much faster way of
identifying the areas will be already
identified and designated and it's
almost this almost needs the industry to
come up private investors going that's
it i put 10 million pound here or a 100
million pound here and we can connect
because there will be
the other thing is that heat networks
have been an unregulated sector
uh it heat was not regulated um in for
heat networks so if
if if the supplier disconnects then
nine out of 10 times the contracts are
covered however because it's unregulated
there was nothing for consumers to go to
but because now it's going to be on the
energy act next year which is postponed
due to pandemic we are hoping for this
to be regulated soon
and hopefully we'll have the same
regulator as we have for gas and
electricity which would bring more
growth and confidence in the market
hope that's answers
yesterday
hi i'm not sure if this is working or
not oh it is now um
clearly one of the barriers to the
rollout of heat networks is is skills
and technical knowledge um
our bay is working closely with other
government departments perhaps education
and higher level skills to
try to help us find a solution to some
of this
yes
so as part of our heat network
transformation program
one of the main part is the heat network
skills program
and what we are doing this year is to
understand a bit more details so we did
a whole skills research report more than
happy to share it with everyone
on where are the places in heat networks
where the skills are really need to be
zoomed in so if you think any more
government interventions so that was
part a and our part b is learning from
our own projects and working with
industry to develop these skills further
so yes it's it's on in the pipeline and
working and i was just having a
conversation with peter uh as well about
this um and i met lisa and anglia uh lep
that how can we join forces with the
labs and the energy hubs and work
together um and we're all we're
discussing with the heat pump department
as well the electrification uh green job
skills task force so lots happening at
the minute but all needs to begin but
really good question thank you
any more questions
you can put your hand up and we'll get
the microphone to you
thank you
from the eastern new energy project
and my question is
many people in the uk they're used to
having their own boiler or their own
heating system and having that control
so my question is is there
or how do you propose to bring people
along with you and
get them to accept this new way of
heating their homes which potentially is
different to how they've done it before
it means them giving up control
some some element of control of their
heating system so how would you bring
them along with you i'm so glad you
asked you almost have i had missed that
point as a barrier when i was asked the
question by the cons counselor
yes we are quite
i think we like that control in our
houses that we want to switch on the off
boiler when we want
um
however when the system starts thinking
about the reduced the lowest pens per
kilowatt hour and if some if the offer
comes to us on
heat price is going to be seven or eight
pence per kilowatt hour as compared to
others
i think that can drive the consumers to
um and i'll give you a few examples so i
was talking to the danish colleagues the
other day uh in a conference
and um
there was a new lady who had started
into the old
association and she she found it quite
strange that we control our boilers
because over there it's it's a thinking
of it's a hassle-free thing you don't
have to look after your boiler because
it's done centrally by a property
management person or a another developer
um and they were like why do you um
it was unfortunate but that day my
plumber was coming to service the boiler
and this whole concept of
arranging it organizing it and then
having the plan was quite new to them so
i think there are things and i'm not
saying that heat networks is a solution
everywhere it would be a beneficial or
low cost at one and probably heat pumps
or hydrogenates or another place
but definitely you've got a waste heat
source so another example of deep
geothermal if you've got
an opportunity of taking out 80 degrees
of temperature directly from ground
drill it up you don't even need to do
the energy efficiency measures to an nth
degree to the houses because you're
directly connected to your pipes so i
think it's it is a mindset mind shift
change um and again coming back to that
role of private sector so it needs to be
done together uh we have a heat network
industry council as well we're working
towards such barriers which you've just
mentioned
good morning
um i've uh robbie from e-screen energy
we design and support this on yeah we
design and supply and install district
heating systems i've recently had an
inquiry for
25 houses to go onto a biomass boiler
we've read your policy document and it
says that the cut off the minimum
requirement is 100 houses for a district
to get grant funding for a district
heating system and that will without any
grant funding the system won't be
installed so am i correct in thinking
that it is a minimum of 100 houses
which document is that referred into
well so i was looking on my phone to try
and find it but it it's the document
that has just recently been released
well the hidden building strategy
document
that that i think that's correct i'll
i'll have a look at the reference
because the importance is the
and as as you work in district heating
sector yourselves it's the importance is
the minimum megawatt hours or the
gigawatt hours rather than the number of
it could be equivalent of heat
uh demand of x number of homes but the
idea is you should have minimum like two
gigawatt hours per year for instance
which is commented zoning consultation
but it's um and i'm sure definitely
you've seen the zoning consultation if
not then please please um uh give me
your email address and i'll send it to
you yeah i believe it said rural was 100
houses and um in cities cities and towns
which i guess was meaning flats it was
300 it's dwellings sorry rather than
houses it was 300 dwellings which i
guess is is aimed at flats
rural to have a hundred dwellings you
know we're not
rural there aren't that many
developments of a hundred house well the
developments of 100 houses but in in
this specific incidence there's 25 a
cluster of 25 buildings
but it would appear that there isn't any
grant funding available
i i can confirm that for you and come
back to you um
because it needs to be aligned with
green heap network fund which is in
scheme design at the minute so
definitely come back to you thank you
very much indeed for that just just one
more question before we move on to our
next speaker
hello there um samuel from the suffolk
chamber on behalf of uh size well c
supply chain team um i'm just wondering
one of one of the things or one of the
two of the byproducts of the nuclear
power station
happens to be
heat
and uh of course hydrogen
and i know that edf
size were quite eager to speak to
businesses
or um you know
companies that specialize in those two
fields so i'm just wondering if you're
having that conversation with
edf size well
as
you know
we're all quite you know i'm a novice
certainly to the nuclear sector and i'm
learning in the job as it were but this
seemed like a great opportunity you know
perhaps to have the cons those
conversations
are you are you in those conversations
at the moment so we do speak with the
big sexes as part because most of them
um so sse entry eon they all have hands
in district heating um
edf um smaller networks at the minute
and then growing more i think from a
blue labs perspective but more than
happy to speak to your contact because
and thanks for identifying um that
source as well it's it's on the list but
as you know it's not widely used at the
minute in uk and it's in plethora of the
he the sources the heat
range of sources
and more than happy to connect you with
my side of contacts for etf as well
thank you very much indeed i'm sure
you'll join me in thanking shivali for
the keynote speech this morning yes with
a round of applause